alexis poulard bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors
l'union européenne a appelé vendredi les
états membres à accélérer les
ratifications nationales du mécanisme
permettant de financer le plan de
relance massif past co-lead dont les
premiers versements pourrait intervenir
au début de l'été alors où est ce que
nous en sommes alexis alors oui on se
rappelle en juillet dernier quand les 27
ont signé ce plan de relance et on parle
de quelque chose d'exceptionnel
d'historique d'inédits 750 milliards
pour les pays européens
390 milliards d'euros qui seraient sous
forme de subventions et 360 milliards
sous forme de prêt c'est-à-dire une
dette commune l'union elle accepterait
que tous sans dette pour pouvoir prêter
seulement voilà les états ne vont
toucher que 13 % de subventions en 2021
la france c'est 5 milliards d'euros on
est loin de 40 milliards annoncés par
bruno l'honneur en l'occurrence
et puis les versements s'étalent
jusqu'en 2023 l'idée bien entendu c'est
de pouvoir aider les pays européens à la
relance mais il y à des conditions bien
entendu c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
seuls six pays ont signé dont la france
et beaucoup d'autres encore hésite parce
que derrière le plan de relance les
conditions sont que les investissements
doivent orienter l'économie vers
davantage de décarbonisation de
l'économie est davantage de
dématérialisation également de
l'économie alors par exemple qu'est ce
qui est demandé à la france et bien
c'est une réforme systémique celle des
retraites évidemment qui avait été
pourtant refusé majoritairement par les
partenaires sociaux
elle va être remis sur la table c'est
aussi des assouplissements dans le
domaine des services pour la hongrie
c'est un changement radical des
attributions des marchés publics
alors voilà ce que demande madame von
der leyen la commission européenne on
comprend que certains ne souhaitent pas
signé il souhaite discuter davantage
pour bruno le maire s'est entendu là on
a vu le ministre de l'économie
parler encore et encore de cette réforme
des retraites qu'il va falloir faire de
toute façon quoi qu'il en coûte donc
pour lui il devient ce plan de relance
et il fera tout pour que la réforme
systémique demandé lieu à d'ailleurs
alexis le ministre de l'économie doit
rencontrer aujourd'hui dans le
commissaire européen à l'économie
oui alors cette petite visite de
courtoisie
imagine paume ouverte même si en janvier
ils s'impatientent est parce que
justement la france a besoin d'argent
sans quoi la reprise ne pourrait pas
arriver sera pas à la hauteur des
prévisions de bercy
alors ce que veut bruno le maire c'est
surtout ce même d'accord j'ai entendu
sur le calendrier
c'est aussi le temps de tout faire une
communication à l'endroit des pays qui
hésitent encore qui n'ont pas signé pour
dire que la france
elle s'engage qu'elle est d'accord à
faire les réformes qu'elle va tout faire
pour que cette relance arrive mais il
faut voir que les 40% du fonds de
relance financés par l'ue n'arrivent pas
en 2001 cantal donc ce sera compliqué
quand même je pense que les négociations
vont être de ce niveau là mais ne sont
pas par exemple sur l'annulation de la
dette publique puisque ce débat alliance
est en ce moment en disant mais c'est
vrai si ces milliards inventé en
écriture par la banque centrale
européenne
est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas un moment
les annuler et quand la relance et à la
hausse voir comment organiser ce
remboursement
ces discussions techniques sont en cours
mais pas avec bruno le maire pas pour le
moment je crois que ce rendez vous
d'aujourd'hui et surtout un plan de
communication à l'encontre des autres
partenaires en terre mais en tout cas
alexis qui est ce qui va rembourser ce
plan de relance oui c'est toute la
question alors les responsables
politiques nous diront que non aucun
impôt nouveau ne sera levé pour les
contribuables européens il faut tout
faire pour éviter que ce soit nous qui
payons de notre poche ce plan de relance
alors il est question là d'un texte pour
recréer des nouvelles ressources propres
de l'union européenne
ça fait un serpent de mer ça fait
longtemps qu'on entend parler de ces
nouvelles ressources propres de l'union
européenne l'idée ce serait de taxer les
géants du numérique les gars ça même
taxe la femme de taxer aussi les pleurs
les gros producteurs de carbone rien
n'est encore mis sur la date beaucoup de
discussions en l'occurrence faut savoir
que de ce plan de relance
les séances plan de remboursement c'est
à peu près de 17 milliards par an et ce
à 2028 à 2058 donc il va falloir trouver
cet argent et de temps que l'union
européenne décide de nouvelles
ressources propres de ce vote au sein du
conseil de l'union européenne ça va être
difficile à mon avis de mettre d'accord
tous les pays on voit par exemple le mal
qu'ont les partenaires européens à
lutter contre les paradis fiscaux à 31
que son du tambour la belgique les pays
bas par exemple puisqu'il faut un vote à
l'unanimité
donc je ne vois pas comment de nouvelles
taxes pourraient voir le jour de manière
facile d'ici la fin de l'année il est
loin d'avoir déjà des deux militaires
des taxes numérique des taxes carbone
mais je crois que ce qui nous attend du
moins pour la france ce sont des
restrictions budgétaires avec de
moindres services publics beaucoup moins
de fonctionnaires et puis cette fameuse
réforme des retraites qui aurait
pourtant dû déjà le pays dans les rues
il y a quelques mois qui risquent de
revenir de manière assez violente dans
les négociations sociales en france
donc affaire à suivre mais je ne crois
pas que rapidement l'union européenne y
trouvera de nouveaux fonds propres
merci beaucoup alexis pour votre édito
alexis poulain editora retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux via les comptes de rt
france